hey guys it's justine and behind me is
the brand new rivien r1s and this is the
suv version of the rivian you guys may
have seen some of the trucks but this
thing is so awesome
and did you hear that it sounds like a
little chirp my sister and i got a
chance to test this out and we're
actually in yosemite right now driving
this around testing it my sister has
definitely been doing more of the
driving than i have but this has been so
much fun so let's hop in and let's chat
about it
so great
[Music]
so now that we're gonna be hopping in we
have two options with us right now we
actually have the little key fob which
is like a little carabiner and this is
amazing because you can just hook this
on to
your belt your backpack whatever and
there's also the key card you can use
your phone and rivien also has a few
other options too they even have like a
wristband that allows you to unlock this
but we basically have been using the
phone pretty much for the entire trip
but since we have the key fob let's
unlock
and chat about this incredible suv oh
it's so amazing
oh
the heated seats are on too so now that
we're inside this thing is so spacious
and that was one of the things i was
most excited about because on our
impromptu trip here we went with our
parents i'm just gonna be honest i pack
a lot no matter what i'm going for or
where the amount of gear the amount of
clothes the amount of things that i pack
it's excessive and add in three other
people we were able to fit so much in
this it was absolutely shocking about to
load up the rivian let's go
[Music]
i love that this has a frunk of course
since there's no engine in the front
like most vehicles you're able to store
so much in there and it even has an
emergency lock which we did test if you
happen to find yourself inside of the
franc there is a little release where
you can press a button and you'll be
able to get out which is an incredible
safety feature i don't recommend doing
that and rivien also doesn't recommend
doing that but the fact that that
feature is there i think is very very
important something else about the front
that's really cool is you can actually
use it as a cooler there's a little plug
that you can unplug to be able to let
out water if you did put ice in there so
this really is one of those vehicles
that you can kind of make whatever you
need it to be like if you need your
frunk to be a cooler you can do that
this does have seven seats in it and for
our configuration that we have right now
on the road trip we put the last two
seats back and those folded down and
we're able to store all of our luggage
and everything in the back it also has a
little secret compartment which you can
store more stuff in which is so amazing
like when i say that you can fit a lot
of stuff in here i am not exaggerating
now also inside of that little secret
compartment is a first aid kit and
there's an air compressor which is
actually really helpful because if you
are off-roading or if you're going on a
beach or sandy conditions or if there's
dirt and you need to let some air out of
your tires to kind of make your way
through whatever it is that you're
trying to get through and then once
you're out you need to add the air and
you're in the middle of nowhere how do
you do that well rivian's got you
covered a built-in air compressor i also
really like this because i can fill up
my bike tires when i'm at home
there's a bike rack accessory my sister
from the back seat has said actually i
added that on to my pre-order was the
bike rack accessory there's even like a
surfboard accessory there's so many
other accessories that you can get for
the rack up top and even a tent they
have just so many accessories and i
think that's one of the cool things is
because we need to also remember that
this is still very early for rivian
somebody had sent a tweet that i think
they were trying to offend me by saying
vivian just got started there are so
many other evs that have been around for
a long time and after driving this
if this is rivian just getting started
oh my goodness having this be a
pre-production model i was definitely
expecting there to be errors or the
maybe some laggy software or things not
working and we have honestly had no
issues whatsoever and i was really
surprised by that just knowing how many
times i've tested a lot of pre-release
software or pre-release products
everything has worked so seamless and
i'm so incredibly impressed so like i
said if this is the beginning i cannot
wait to see the future of rivia my
sister actually pre-ordered one a really
long time ago and at the time i didn't
really need to do a car upgrade and i'm
so jealous because the second that i
opened up this door when rivian brought
this over for us i immediately regretted
not rewarding years ago so the color of
this is really beautiful they do have a
bunch of other options that you can
configure on the website so not only can
you configure the interior the exterior
but you can also configure various wheel
types and this color is the lcap granite
which is quite fitting because we are
here in yosemite and we even got some
video footage of the lcap granite in
front of el capitan
this is the launch edition package and
this has all of the same contents as the
adventure package so you can choose
between the two but with the adventure
package it changes the interior badging
you have free wheel upgrades and you
have access to the limited launch green
exterior color this also has the large
battery pack which will estimate about
360 miles of range with the quad motor
depending upon which wheels you do
decide it does say on the website some
of them will give you less range some
will give you more so depending upon
what the look is that you're going for
or what you plan on doing with the car
that will depend how much range you'll
get these are the 22-inch sport wheels
bright they partnered with pirelli to
develop these specifically for their
vehicles and their unique capabilities
so the current package that i'm sitting
in right now runs about 95 000 this is
the adventure quad motor large pack lcap
granite 22 inch bright wheels with the
black mountain interior and it has the
tow hooks you can go zero to 60 in three
seconds and did we test that yep you
better believe it then straighten it out
yep hold on straighten out again one two
sexy yeah that felt like it was in zero
or three seconds and we were also on an
incline it's also cooled out so the
battery's not prepped
this has a towing capacity of seven
thousand seven hundred pounds it has
various drive modes there's all-purpose
sport conserve towing off-road and crawl
something that is really cool to kind of
witness which i'll show you guys here in
a second is the way that you can adjust
the suspension okay so right now we're
in the high setting and i'm gonna take
it down to the low and this is taking us
down to 10.1 inches
there's also a highest and lowest
setting as well
look at this we're going down
this has completely changed my shot this
is great okay i'm gonna go back up dude
this thing is so
great i love it it is definitely getting
dark speaking of getting dark there's
actually a flashlight right here in
the side like this is so great like what
a great idea there's also another fun
little addition right here under the
center console and this discharges
inside of the car which is so awesome
because you never know when you might
need to
have some music out in the wilderness if
you want it you've got it now since this
is an suv one of the other things that i
love is the back hatch now what is
unique about this is the fact that i've
seen this in other vehicles too but i
love that they have this included is
there's a top and a bottom hatch so if
you have a bunch of stuff in there and
you don't want it to go rolling around
you're able to kind of just open up the
top and that little bottom half stays
put so all of your stuff doesn't go
rolling out and something that has
really made it easy to put luggage and
gear in and out of this is you're able
to adjust this little ramp right here so
if it's down you can see this little
ridge right here but if you lift it up
it's a nice flat and smooth so you can
put in your gear or rivien recommends
going out and stargazing and you can be
super cozy with some blankets the
panoramic glass roof is so awesome and
even on our way up here it was really
hot it was like 115 degrees on the drive
up and it is uv coated to protect you
from getting a sunburn and even though
it was that hot i was actually quite
surprised because i thought that it
would have more of an effect on the
drive up and it really wasn't that bad
at all i do like that there are air
conditioned seats in the front and also
heated seats in the front and the back
and that does vary between if you get
the adventure pack or the explorer pack
it was nice because the model that we
have does have air conditioned seats in
the front and it also since like right
now it's actually quite cold it does
have heated seats so i've had that on
and just having like a nice little spa
day so the entire trip here was really
fun and i was concerned because
obviously i think this is a lot of
concerns that a lot of people have when
getting an electric vehicle what is the
charging like it does take a little bit
of extra planning because you do have to
map out your route but what is great is
in the dashboard we're able to put in
our start and put in our end location
and it gives you suggestions of where
you should charge depending upon how
many charges are along the way and what
we did is we actually mapped ours a
little bit differently than what it
suggested depending upon what we wanted
to do so we found some cool restaurants
was able to charge for like an hour and
a half for lunch all right time to feast
and then hit the road i am watching the
charging and then we continued on our
way and then we had to do a bathroom
break so we found a walmart and there we
were able to charge for like another 30
minutes while we shopped got some things
for the trip so i've been eating
popsicles napping i'm having a great
time over yeah how's your experience as
a passenger oh you're doing a great job
keep it up okay dad how's your
experience great mom great everybody
having a good time
and here at the lodge there is actually
a fast charger so we've been driving
around all day and coming back and being
able to charge overnight in the park
though they do have rivien branded
chargers so that's pretty great to know
that that option is there if we need it
we tested it out and we charged a little
bit but since the car was pretty much
charged already we didn't really need to
spend much time there and it's great
though because everything is connected
to the app we could be out and about
roaming having lunch or doing whatever
it is that we need to do and can always
check on it on the app well that's it i
just wanted to give you guys a quick
little overview and how awesome it's
been to test this out i've been a huge
fan of rivian i've loved the r1t and
it's been really cool to check out the
r1s especially here in like adventure
town everyone has been stopping me and
my sister and wanting to see it wanting
to talk about it we've made so many
friends so if any of you met us along
the way hi i'm justine and that's jenna
in the car and pretty sure uh jed and i
sold a few pre-orders here so rivien you
know we just we did we did our best
a huge thank you to rivien though for
letting us borrow this because this was
such a fun trip and i have been dying to
go on a road trip and this was the
perfect opportunity and it was so much
fun to get to hang out with my sister
and my parents there's jenna
i mean the fact that our parents even
came along like they extended their trip
to make this trip happen and since they
were in the back seat for most of the
time they were quite comfy back there
and it's great to just see something
like this still have so much leg room
and space if you're in the back seat
because i know as a back seat passenger
sometimes it can get a little cramped
back there and they had a ton of room
and even in the third row when those
seats are up there's still a lot of room
back there there's a lot of room back
here there's a lot of room
if anybody questions if there's not
enough room in the back seat like
there's a ton of room back here so this
thing has absolutely exceeded my
expectations and i am so excited for my
sister to get one i definitely was
playing around with pre-orders so i may
or may not have pre-ordered one as well
the white just looks so so fresh and all
the accessories oh my god i'm just i'm
freaking out okay i'm gonna go because
the sun is going down and the moon is
gonna come up and long ago somebody
probably left with the cup
if you know you know
[Music]